♪ ♪
>> Judge Jeanine: IT IS A WOKE
WORLD AFTER ALL.
HERE'S TO RIDICULOUS STORIES OF
LEFTIST ABSURDITY.
STANFORD UNIVERSITY RELEASING
ITS GUIDE TO ELIMINATE "HARMFUL
LANGUAGE."
APPARENTLY CALLING YOURSELF AN
AMERICAN IS A DIRTY WORD.
SO INSTEAD USE "U.S. CITIZEN."
THAT'S NOT ALL.
BROWN BAG LUNCHES ARE RACIST.
SAY LUNCH AND LEARN.
IN PLACE OF "YOU GUYS," USE
"FOLKS" OR "PEOPLE."
TRY SWITCHING OUT "KILLING TWO
BIRDS WITH ONE STONE"
ACCOMPLISHING TWO THINGS AT
ONCE.
THAT'S NOT ALL THE WOKE
INSANITY.
A FILM CRITIC IS PUTTING THE
MOVIE AVATAR 2 ON GLASS OVER
WHITE
PEOPLE PLAYING.
>> Neil: WHITE ACTORS
COSPLAYING AS PEOPLE OF COLOR.
HOW DOES ANY OF THIS HELP US?
>> Jesse: IT DOESN'T.
HOW DOES SHE KNOW WHITE ACTORS
ARE PLAYING BLUE ALIENS?
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT'S THE
NEXT QUESTION.
ARE THEY BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST?
THEY SAY YOU CAN'T USE
"AMERICAN" BECAUSE THAT REFERS
TO PEOPLE FROM THE UNITED STATES
ONLY IN SUBMITTING THAT THE
UNITED STATES IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT COUNTRY IN THE
AMERICAS.
YEAH, IT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
COUNTRY.
I DON'T THINK HONDURAS IS SAYING
GUYS, WHAT ABOUT ME.
ALSO, THE I.T. DEPARTMENT AT
STANFORD PUT THIS TOGETHER.
FIX MY COMPUTER, DUDE.
WHEN ARE YOU GETTING INVOLVED IN
THE LANGUAGE FOR?
LEAVE THAT TO THE ENGLISH
DEPARTMENT PAY THE ENGLISH
DEPARTMENT ISN'T TRYING TO DO
THAT.
THEY TEACH YOU IN ENGLISH.
YOU PROBABLY MAJORED IN ENGLISH.
USE COLORFUL LANGUAGE, GRAPHIC
LANGUAGE, EUPHEMISMS TO DRAW THE
READER IN.
IF IT SOUNDS TOO PRECLINICAL, NO
ONE'S GOING TO WANT TO READ IT.
THEY ARE LOOKING OUT FOR KAREN.
THEY SAY KAREN IS OFFENSIVE AND
THEY WANT YOU TO SAY INSTEAD
"DEMANDING OR ENTITLED WHITE
WOMAN."
DOES THE KAREN REALLY WANT TO BE
CALLED THE "DEMANDING AND
ENTITLED WHITE WOMAN?"
I BET NOT.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHY DO WE
CAPITULATE TO THESE FOOLS?
WHY DO WE GIVE THEM A MOMENT?
>> Tom: OR AN INCH.
THEN THEY WILL TAKE A MILE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THIS, IT ALMOST
MAKES SENSE.
IF YOU GIVE IN A LITTLE BIT,
THEN THE ARGUMENT ABOUT AVATAR
MAKES SOME KIND OF SENSE.
BECAUSE NOW ANYONE WHO DOES ANY
KIND OF A CHANGE OF COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN IS RACIST WHICH THIS
TERRIBLE FOR ME BECAUSE I WANT
THE AUDIENCE TO KNOW, I AM
WEARING BROWN MAKEUP RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: [LAUGHS]
>> Tom: IMAGINE IF I DIDN'T
WEAR BROWN MAKEUP.
IMAGINE WHAT I WOULD LOOK LIKE
ON TV.
WE ALL CHANGE OUR COLOR.
PEOPLE MAKE FUN OF ME.
THAT'S A JOKE.
WE ARE LAUGHING AT THAT PAY
PEOPLE FEEL ENTITLED TO LAUGH AT
ME BECAUSE I GUESS I'M
PRIVILEGED.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PRIVILEGES.
I WENT TO THE VIRGIN ISLANDS AND
THE LOCAL CHILDREN, I WAS ON THE
BEACH.
THEY LITERALLY CIRCLED ME AND
LAUGHED AND MADE FUN OF ME.
>> Jesse: BECAUSE YOU ARE SO
PALE AND THIN?
>> Tom: THEY WERE POINTING AT
ME AND SAYING "WHITE, WHITE,
WHITE, WHITE."
LOOK AT HOW WHITE HE IS.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT'S THE
POINT, LIKE THEY ARE ALL
VICTIMS.
THE STATUS OF VICTIMHOOD.
>> Dana: HAVE VERY GOOD FRIEND
WHO WILL GO NAMELESS, AT
STANFORD IS A PROFESSOR.
HE SAID HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
WHY THE I.D. DEPARTMENT IS SO
LIBERAL.
THIS IS REALLY COMING FROM THE
I.T. DEPARTMENT AND THE REST OF
THE FACULTY JUST IGNORES ALL OF
THIS.
THINKS IT'S RIDICULOUS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT POINT
OUT.
THEY SAY YOU CAN SAY "BRAVE,"
BECAUSE IT PERPETUATES THE
STEREOTYPE OF THE NOBLE, BRAVE
SAVAGE, WHICH TO ME IS MORE
OFFENSIVE THAN JUST SAYING THE
WORD BRAVE.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jesse: WHAT ABOUT
"BRAVEHEART"?
>> Dana: THERE'S A MILLION
THINGS.
I BELIEVE STANFORD PULLED THIS
DOWN TODAY.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE STANFORD
P.R. DEPARTMENT TODAY.
FINDING OUT, WAIT, FOX NEWS IS
SAYING WHAT?
WHAT ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT?
TRACKING IT DOWN TO THE I.T.
DEPARTMENT AND SAYING FIX MY
COMPUTER.
>> Jesse: LIKE LAST WEEK.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH SAM BANK
BEEN FREED'S PARENTS.
>> Jesse: AND THEY FIRED THEIR
FOOTBALL COACH.
>> Judge Jeanine: THEY SAY YOU
CAN'T SAY "BROWN BAG LUNCH.
CLOSE BUT INSTEAD USE SHOULD SAY
"LUNCH AND LEARN."
JUST BECAUSE I HAVE A BROWN BAG
LUNCH IS A MEAN I WANT TO LEARN
ANYTHING.
HOW DO WE GET TO THE
TRANSLATION?
>> Dana: THEY DON'T WANT YOU
TO SAY BROWN.
>> Judge Jeanine: LUNCH AND
LEARN.
I DON'T WANT TO LEARN.
>> Jessica: BROWN BAG LUNCH IS
NOT JUST FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
JOBS.
I GO TO THESE "LUNCH AND
LEARNS."
SOMEONE DOESN'T PRESENTATION.
BROWN BAG LUNCHES FOR KIDS.
WHAT DO YOU BRING TO SCHOOL?
MOST PEOPLE USE LUNCH BOXES.
>> Judge Jeanine: LUNCH BOXES
FOR 30 YEARS.
>> Jessica: I'M SAYING THAT
IT'S NOT RELEVANT IS MY POINT.
YOU WOULDN'T TELL A 5-YEAR-OLD,
GO TO A "LUNCH AND LEARN" WHEN
YOU GET TO THE CAFETERIA.
>> Tom: YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED
TO HAVE BAGS ANYMORE ANYWAY.
YOU SHOULD WALK AROUND WITH JUST
A SANDWICH IN YOUR HAND.
>> Jessica: THESE THINGS ARE
NEVER REAL.
REMEMBER THE PUSH FOR LATINX, TO
USE THE TERM LATINX AND THEY
POLLED LATINO PEOPLE AND ONLY 3%
WANTED TO BE IDENTIFIED AS
LATINX.
IT'S THE SAME.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT STARTS
WITH POLITICAL CORRECTNESS.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
ARE AFRAID TO TA